this episode is brought to you by gray
block pizza also bronx-born pizza and
gray block is their 1811 Pico Boulevard
in Los Angeles on the way to the beach
and bronx-born
is up there in Bend Oregon and that's
our sister pizza company and we're all
so grateful for them for their support
if you hear me having a snack right now
then you are here and accurately because
I'm having a little bit of that trail
mix the original flavor from lakeside
maple and lakeside maple trail mix is
baked with pure maple syrup you know
sometimes you'll be in Vermont you'll be
in a back alley you'll see somebody
peddling some uh some fake maple you
know some of that fake EMS but this is
pure maple syrup and that's what they
baked into it at lakeside maple they
have three flavors original spicy and
ginger chai which also was a name of um
my stepmothers Bichon actually all of
the mixes at lakeside maple are made by
hand by fans of the podcast that's right
they listen to it while they make this
stuff in their stew in their kitchen and
all of these products are gluten-free
and vegan so if you happen to be one of
those things then this this you can have
this and if you're not you can still
have it it's it's really good and you
can use code Theo
at checkout to receive 15% off your
order get in there and try out the best
trail mix that everyone thinks is
granola but it's not it's trail mix also
try out that trail mix butter and I
don't know if you I mean this stuff is
good I'll say this if you cover somebody
in that trail mix butter and set them
loose on an actual trail they will get
probably kidnapped that's how good that
butter is that somebody would kidnap
somebody who just had it on their body
go to lakeside maple calm and use code
Theo for 15% off your order
I'm have some right now today's guest
you know I must tell you this you know
sometimes you remember those little
troll dolls used to get in middle school
and they had crazy hair and they had
jewels in their belly
hmm I'm not saying this guy's like that
but I'm also not saying he's not like
that you know this is the most asexual
or just mop just multi-sexual I mean I
wouldn't be surprised if you chiseled
this guy's pants open and you found 90
different types of crotches down there
you know just like a garden of
straight-up just rare crotch I mean he's
just that magical omnipresent you know
he's that gender fluid you know just
that beautiful sip of just magic sauce
and he's a nice guy he's a nice guy
I'll say this I wouldn't have an agent
right now in this in this business if it
weren't for this guy who called who
called repeatedly to an agency because
because he believed in me and helped me
get an agent like I wouldn't have won
you know and he did that a lot of
comedians wouldn't do that and I look up
to this guy even though he's so small I
mean he's really a to-go item and we're
so happy that he's here with us today
from the tiger belly podcast it is Bobby
Larew
[Music]
get in here bro huh thanks dude huh we
get to you that little sugar packet too
little sack a freaking dynamite here
yeah their phones are whoa bro we don't
do it all right we used to do it dude
and we had an issue somebody this is a
true story somebody hurt the rear and
then tried to somebody hurt their ear
and then tried to sue us
no I seized it yeah no real yeah I
guessed yeah and I'm not gonna say who
because legally be in the comedian or an
actor huh woman comedian or an actor
comedian yeah definitely comedian so how
many get her Sarah Tiana right she
wouldn't come when Sarah Tiana did that
there's yeah Terrace Tiana's like if it
was a settlement in this town it was a
Sarah though Silverman
oh god no we would never on here um but
yeah what about those two guys dude
Brennan I'm Brian what's going I don't
trust them um they're thick dudes you
know I'm sorry but is it looks like
Brendan's just gonna eat Brian one day
yeah yeah you know I think that he wants
to [ __ ] my girl bro Oh Brendan there's a
vibe there you know it's funny somebody
else's mention that yeah and if you did
well there's nothing much I can do about
you know if I caught them I'd be like
okay free yeah hurry please
but you need to hide in there you could
I could see you hiding under her vagina
in there with like a little raker
Oh bro yeah man you know yeah that's how
we got now more than the war bro hmm
they heated a tree for three weeks with
a banana I can hide a little cans of
cokes mm-hmm
right like a soldier would look at a can
of coke and they're surprising yes sir
probably it takes a sip to his mouth and
then a freaking dagger comes out yeah
man bayonet maybe bayonet
yeah dude a bayonet um what's up Bobby
Lee good it's been this long since I've
never even done your podcast why why'd
you wait for me when all the fools been
on this man whoo yeah really who was
rosenbaum just here yeah he was here
yeah those fools yeah Rosenbaum will
serve me Oh Rosenbaum do you are but you
also don't want to drive across town
very much and you can't drive and play
you know I know whenever there's a new
iOS update and you can't play candy
crush
you don't like to drive during that
you're smart man you know me do you know
me dude all are gonna grow that out man
huh your mall this yam is hair it's
coming in dude I'm growing a pair of
mittens for a kid with cancer Oh charity
yeah charity yeah hand cancel they got a
kid not growing one pubic hair for that
I have one long it doesn't curl my pubes
you know that uh-uh
really yeah ethnic pubic hairs they
don't curl they just could see that he
stick straight out like it's scared
that's like Brian's song you say they
movie Brian's song no man is a good
movie yeah it's sad though but I could
see you uh growing pubic hair like a
really sad song yeah yeah who's this
little [ __ ] a white dude you have
here man that's premature Nick dude he
was a premature baby I can tell man can
you a little yeah his head is like
misshapen yeah
that's not true he's handsome he's
handsome he's an early handsome no he's
got a point I shaved my head in eighth
grade and I got a lumpy lumpy head I can
tell that girl's mad yeah it's like God
um God when he was making you man he was
in a rush right like when he made Brad
Pitt right he spent like three weeks
right like you know like and then with
you is like something down this guy's
was good but the final issues yeah it
was like an early factory deal that they
had yeah God when they made me he made
like
me at the same time you know and we're
all made and then came we came down here
yeah yeah I could have twins dude I was
just in Shanghai man I just got back why
yeah why'd you come back always here for
comedy dude you go they won't get me man
yeah do the Chinese right bro yeah
they're tiny yeah the Chinese don't like
me but Ching chongs don't like weed
really yeah it's ok ching chong or what
are you can i you've never said it
before
look dude here's what I say about I
don't use racial slurs unless you do
know but I was just here bros
fascinating man do you feel and I've
always wanted to ask you this do you
feel Asian like does it feel Asian when
you wake up no that's a that's a funny
thing that's a good question dude that's
ridiculous is it really yeah cuz I wake
up I don't even think about it
really yeah this is what the for I think
what time is it every time I wake up
what time is it right and then I go
that's what I think
where's my phone there's a second thing
yeah and then the third thing is I got a
P yeah me too
then the fourth thing is and you get
some coffee or something yeah any
something together or water or something
through the liquids yeah some many
liberals right then the fifth thing is
in my Asian no you don't think about
even when you look in the mirror you
don't go oh I'm Asian
because the thing is is that I've just
always been this yeah you know I'm on
the Asian stuff in the way I look is
only why people made me aware of that oh
wow
people like you really yeah because you
know when when when I was a kid and they
used to kids used to come and they'd do
the I thing they was to stretch their
eyes like this and go change honk and
all that couldn't we do that to me too
because I have really nice yeah right in
the South people used to call me chop
boy they used to call me um uh Bruce Lee
yeah they used to call me all of that
dude will you offended by it or what um
I guess it kind of hurt my feet just
made me feel like oh maybe I'll look a
little strange you know no but that's
not a strange look
I mean look an Asian when you're polish
and Nicaraguan I think it's kind of a
while that it is a while yeah but when
you were in Shanghai did anyone go
have Chinese I think some people looked
at me like maybe I knew something yeah
you do look like you know something you
know because you don't saying I have
lean eyes I'm lean in the vision the
visual but can I say this it's just
something about Yuma yeah you do you are
one of those trustworthy whites yeah
even when I first met you not you not so
much but when I met you I was like this
guy this guy would never hang me yeah
even if it yeah because you're like me
got there at night and give you water oh
you're like a Schindler yeah while you
were hanging right hang you what the day
before they were gonna hang you I'd
sneak out there that night and give you
water but what if I said hey hey can you
get me out of here I would say I can't
why because they're they're gonna know
they're gonna and I'll die too
okay but I'm gonna die yeah I know you
are buddy
and that also that comforting it doesn't
feel good let it keep going you haven't
[ __ ] let the scene play now okay look
I know you're gonna let's start from the
top a guy okay hold on hold on yeah
so it's nighttime right right and it's
raining what year is that I have to know
what year it is it's whenever you guys
died dude 60 70 okay let's just say 1967
and your Alabama jacked Alabama Alabama
[ __ ] hanging a where's the San
Francisco wasn't where they killed a lot
of Asian people wasn't that where they
now well you know that was in the for in
the 40s during World War two they had
internment camps yeah but they didn't
hang the Japanese they just put him in
camps okay then this was in China where
they did this China they where was that
there was a ton of remember they would
hang him by their by their hair oh yeah
yeah are you that I read a couple books
about this when I was in a room okay so
look yeah pretend I just pretend it's
Alabama okay it's in the 60s cuz you're
a white dude you're southern right okay
yeah so I'm in a cage free but you know
I'm gonna kid about to die the next day
okay they're gonna let me roam free like
I'm how you're in a one of those things
these things Oh
I mean a doctor what do you call those
though a guillotine
no guillotine is a knife on it the
stalks is the stalks my bad no no my bad
yeah I'm gonna stalk your
stocks and so I mean let me get the
first line okay it's raining
thanks for the water even though it's
raining oh yeah didn't know is gonna be
raining yeah but thanks I was parched
no worries choppy chop what'd you call
me
nothing go okay I'm just making sure
you're okay
I'm fine yeah I can they're gonna um I
think they're gonna do something
tomorrow like hang me or something
I don't think hang is like a surprise
party I think oh it is yeah it's not my
birthday or nothing yeah but it's like a
big day for you it is yeah is it what am
i I have a feeling it's gonna be one of
my last days uh oh it depends on how you
look at it like that that's why I'm
actually here right now to talk to you
about Jesus Christ uh yeah no thanks
okay good guide no thanks look guys but
listen um can I just say guy um yeah
what's your name again my name is Reggie
can I call you master Reggie then I mean
you can Bester Reggie oh yeah just don't
say it to you like okay can you sneak me
out of here I'm gonna see what I can do
I can probably come back tomorrow night
and help you tonight I can just give you
water and also have this small bag of
fresh pears oh I love pears thank you I
know you do can you slice them because I
have my hands I can't yeah I'll slice
them okay um but if they're gonna hate
me tomorrow then what's tomorrow night
gonna what is that gonna do yeah it's a
good point actually gonna be a little
late yeah see something inspirational to
me to make me feel calmer
yeah come from me I'm gonna tell you
this that even though a lot of the books
and stuff just showed that God just you
know has like a lot of white people in
heaven that everybody is allowed in
heaven and that you're gonna be up there
and that you're gonna be a king well
like will I be able to go to the white
sections of heaven you can stop by you
know yeah yeah but also there's some
ones that roped off words are offense up
there dude the only thing roped off is
gonna be you tomorrow I'm just joking
guy it's just a surprise oh man
okay well you gonna be you're gonna be
there at the party I'll be there oh but
don't look me in the eyes okay can I
just say something about the scene I
really didn't feel comforted on that
okay I know I'm being real I think this
is my honest truth okay and when I said
that you were
one of the good whites I really meant it
I believe that if I was imprisoned that
you would be really caring you would
have tears in your eyes and you would
really care I don't know if you can do
that as an actor I only have that kind
of depth mm-hmm like Johnny Depp yeah
but I'm just letting you know that joke
around just now but in real life I
really believe that you would make me
cry and go thank you so much sir
okay you can't do it now I don't think I
might be able to I don't really let's
try it real all right so I'm gonna be
real too because okay so here we go
he's just taped yeah okay I think
they're gonna kill me he can't laugh man
you're [ __ ] up it wasn't funny dude
let's do it again sorry I gotta be funny
you're gonna pod cut let's do a scene
that right but the way you looked at me
was so sincere it make me laugh so hard
so let's start all right all right I'm
gonna go this was supposed to do you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I did alright just
look away from me and turn to me like
that when I say my line that's what I
get another shot at it yeah the white
dude I don't know a refuse your brother
order Rico's I'm gonna hang you you goop
tomorrow you flat face [ __ ] I'm scared
time for you to die you little [ __ ]
snap pea is that it medicine let me try
again
no that alright that was looking kind of
just say this why'd you call me that I
mean that's just like an old nickname I
think it wait wait in the it's wait from
where you're from you took my agents
nappies to the look I don't even know
the only person that I know did except
for some like I've seen on the Internet
Ali Wong you know her I know her a
little bit you've been around her though
been around yeah yeah I don't really
know where how much you're feeling with
us so let me think when I get around
Asian people for the first couple times
I was very very nervous here's what I
feel like I feel like for me it's really
hard for me to know what you guys
emotions are like I know like white
emotion because I've been around it you
know I are easy but Asian people I feel
like they never pay attention to me yeah
I feel like that they don't care about
white people and I feel phrasing
really that's insane but they never say
anything
yeah well the ones that don't speak
English maybe they don't say anything to
me either but it seems weird if you care
like I don't know they just seem hard to
interact like well I look at me right
now
I love you I love you to know I really
do love you I love you too as a human
being in all of you - zine and does that
feel good or no yeah I believe you
you do believe me yeah I was lying a
little good acting yeah that was like if
you died I would just be like what Leo
died I'd be like oh okay
yeah we just move on with my day dude I
know this you guys are gonna control the
future though I was just in China and
bro that is you guys are coming in hot
but there were oh there were hey I mean
some guy jumped off of a building killed
himself
yeah seven Asian people came out of him
like just a lot like it's long ending
bro it's not ending with the Asians it's
full you guys are going full throttle so
we're like most of heaven is Asians you
realize that why because it's like I
mean there's a lot of Chinese people
that believe in heaven and Japanese
people and Laotian who else you guys
have welcome I'm Korean so you missed us
but the Koreans is that dumb but the
number one religion in Korea is
Christianity yeah but that that's only
true if Christianity is true right you
believe it you believe Christianity is
true I believe that Jesus was a good
role model right what do I believe is
true that when you die what are you
gonna see for
me the thing that seems most plausible
is reincarnation and I believe that
because the only thing I know is that
I've been here so reincarnate like to
think that oh you could come back here
well yeah that makes sense I've I've
been here once it's the only thing I
really know is that I've been here once
we will wait once before the own time
all right right so I have some proof
that I could come back yeah you know
like that seems plausible do you think I
could wake up somewhere else I got a you
know a big Benihana in the sky or
somewhere everybody's [ __ ] party and
in doing it you know doing karaoke and
[ __ ] you know I drag it up Laurie I
think I could absorb to buy some sort of
infinite energy mm-hmm where just listen
but they go oh when after I say my thing
okay I explain myself yeah my bad let's
see Mauer
I'm gonna say it again I don't want okay
what Bobby thinks have give me something
else what Bobby thinks happens when I
feel when I die I feel like I'm gonna
get absorbed by some infinite energy
yeah it sounds exciting yes so basically
it's like like what do you mean infinite
I'll tell you what I'm like horizon yeah
like frozen yeah know that I'm not
self-aware like oh I'm Bobby Lee in this
increment energy I'm just a part of this
thing and there's no more I I'm just a
I've just you know there's no like self
identity okay do you think that's gonna
be freeing or do you think honestly do
you think it's gonna feel very freeing
or do you think that's gonna feel very I
don't think there's gonna be any feeling
of sad or anything that's the thing
there's no because I'm absorbed in this
infinite energy of a positive energy
right you know God's God's jizz mm-hmm
like EJ yeah if God had jizz I'm a part
of his jizz and some people say Jesus
Christ they do you know people say that
well do you think don't
okay so you won't know then but right
now you have thoughts towards it do you
think right now that you will be
disappointed that you'll no longer be
yourself or know that it's you or do you
feel like you will feel freed from what
confines a part of me that feel
it's a waste because I've learned so
much and I've experienced so much and as
such I have good memories I have some
bad ones too but molested and whatnot
yeah but that's so long ago yeah
yesterday yeah your girls just trying to
get some money like an elevator but my
point is is this no I was one as a kid I
did but you know I have all these life
experiences and I have relationships
that go but way back deep and those are
the things that I wish I could take with
me mm-hmm
because it's a waste it feels like it's
a waste if it's just like nothingness
right
but you know I'm you know I've been
sober for a long time and I have to kind
of believe that there is an omnipotent
omnipresent mmm-hmm
love energy out there that the
omnipotent same thing it's the same
thing yeah potatoes potatoes yeah yeah
but that's I have to believe that I do
believe in a you know God sort of speak
but I don't believe in Christianity I
don't believe that being gays and
abomination no I don't believe any of
those things either do you I don't but
that I know I believe that God I believe
you can be gay and be in heaven I
believe you could be straight and be in
heaven I think you could I don't think
you can be a real piece of [ __ ] that
would be there
yeah but Christians don't believe that
well general but I think a lot of I
think there's some old-school real
old-school like by the book but I think
those people are so few and far between
that that's ridiculous you really do a
hundred percent I'm from that area like
well my friends who believe in Jesus
Christ don't also I don't think that
they believe and there are harder in
their mind that gay people aren't
allowed in heaven you know yeah of them
have a gay family member they're not
gonna you know you're not gonna leave
your family somewhere um I think that's
an old I I think that's an old idea it's
so weird that you say that because when
I go to the south and then when I go to
those parts of the country in my head
because I mean I don't I don't want to
talk about politics but no because Trump
is such you know I mean he there is what
he's got a 45 percent uh provable rating
yeah so there is a chunk of American
society
that thinks and believes the polar
opposite of what I believe so I believe
when I'm in those areas that they're
around so I act weird right I think I
act more Asian because I don't want to
you know I don't want to get into it
right so when people go I even have an
accent yeah like how you doing a little
boy I do that Hawaii
do you take like a well dude I used to
have dreams that I was an under I was
like you know Undercover Boss member
that show yeah but I was like a slave
like I would gone back in time right and
I was a Undercover Boss and like a slave
thing oh you're doing the slave work
with them yes to see if they're doing it
see if they're doing it right yeah right
and then if they don't weren't you would
reveal yourself at the end of the show
yeah and go hey I'm the master yeah
don't you think they would know that you
were the master already ah they didn't
know Oh cuz you have so many slaves I've
had a recurring dream but here's the
thing I never get to the end I just get
to the beginning there's this one slave
named Lila actually and he lilac yeah
like a flower yeah beautiful name I
think it's a man but he he's the hardest
worker Oh Lila cos yeah
and so he won't stop working because I'm
trying to get him to free oh my gosh
tomorrow we're gonna be free and half
I'm more like hell yeah yeah and I looks
like can't go got to work tomorrow
oh he's one of those yeah at the end of
the episode when you interview with
lilac he wins and you go you can live in
you can live in the house you can live
wherever you when you get your own house
whoa you get him his own house
he's from sheep he gets her own horse he
could turn a car that was a car back
then a horse
oh yeah the horse was the car a new car
yeah yeah but what if Lila is like I
want to go north well do that but that's
the thing about like he's such a company
man he's like okay that's a good thing
though I agree it's not but for the
undercover but for the slideshow yeah
for your own mind show yeah it'll show
that you have in your [ __ ] [ __ ]
dream yeah whatever your [ __ ] mind
show I call them your little mind show
12 years of slave could have been six
years of slave okay they [ __ ] made it
12 to make the movie longer to make
money so let's be honest about what the
[ __ ]
really yeah yeah Oh Holley first of all
Hollywood's of bro two years ago black
people were bagging they get Academy
Awards Hollywood's [ __ ] diverse eat a
dick man there's no where's all the
Asian people that are should be in
where's all the Latinos that should be
in [ __ ] film and television oh we're
in television and film you know what it
is and you know being a guy that's you
know yeah I've been in the outskirts of
Hollywood but I've worked here and there
you know and um what it was
in the 90s when I came to LA is not what
it is today really in the 90s if I got
an audition I'm not even kidding you
this is not a joke I would show up at an
audition and everyone would be in ninja
costumes really with the masks and
everything you can only see their eyes
oh why am i there's no lines either so
just pick one yeah it could be any of
that
yeah there's no lines there in the new
job it doesn't [ __ ] matter
yeah even if they take the mask off
they're all Asian it doesn't matter yeah
that one
ching ching whatever you know oh right
but I used to show up to those with no
ninja masks because I wanted to be like
different oh wow right and they go
where's your outfit I got over great
what amazing yeah yeah but those were
the audition like a mom's fat yeah I you
know I auditioned with a buddy I
remember like all these like Asian
actors that you know now I'm Arnold he's
no nation but it when he sweats and he
can he's very Asian when it's wet yeah
yeah because it goes into his eyes and
dance right yeah but um I auditioned for
a movie called do you remember Peter
Jackson did King Kong yes do you know
there was a movie called King Kong yeah
you're aware of that
yep and Peter Jackson also did Lord of
rings Lord of the Rings yeah so Peter
Jackson did King Kong Jack Black was in
it it one thing I thought you said you
didn't know I didn't that person know I
know okay now you know an Adrian Brody
yes thank you
Wow I loved Adrien Brody in the pianist
a very good such a great movie great
yeah great a great actor underrated and
then he disappeared he got into sex and
drugs I think no no he's in said is he
really yeah I just gotta watch more
stuff you know
but what happened so you know basic so
there was a so the role was in that
movie weren't you know I was in the
[ __ ] movie bro huh
but anyway there was one Chinese guy in
it uh-huh he had no line
Wow if you saw the movie he ran he ran
away from King Kong screaming yeah but
we all are dissing for that part ah so
it was me and a bunch of Asian actor
we're sitting there for an hour's Wow
and then you walked into a room and they
had a cardboard cutout of King Kong I
got the wall right and the catheter goes
okay so King Kong a pairs and so just
just run I hope it's a room it's yeah
just in a circle or whatever and I go
you want me just run so I run this is
worse than my lie like I run in a circle
hmm I think she'll stop stop I'll breath
um what she goes can you scream I mean
it's King Kong it's like you're scared
yes I know you didn't see my face I was
like petrified you know is it I know but
just
actually I do it again right bicycle ah
at screaming in a room running a circle
I'm sweating Wow
and then she go stop and she goes it
just doesn't sound agen oh I go what the
screen yeah it just it feels like you're
just American screaming yeah do it again
right
so I swear to god this is what I did
yeah you know what I did what I got it
caught it she goes thank you I leave the
room I'm sweating right and I stayed in
the lobby because I wanted to see the
facial expressions of all the actors
coming out of the world of just complete
defeat Wow and sadness and none of them
could make any yeah I mean it was so
humiliating I didn't get the part
obviously dude but that's basically what
it generally was but now yeah you know
we can have like I want us to come now
yeah and I just speak regular like
everyone else is it good somebody said
it's not any good
who's it that huh yeah yeah yeah I mean
but they also said they didn't put you
on the Billboard they didn't know I know
what is that and they put four whites on
the Billboard I know but you know that's
show biz is it yeah because I'm gonna
tell you right now
I don't give a [ __ ] I know I look I know
you don't care I don't think I care I
know you care at least it looks
interesting to me it looks like oh how
does Bobby Lee relate with these people
yeah I'm just riding on the footboard
I'm the fat ethnic guy who's friends
with the lead mm-hmm
so I come and I say a couple of lines I
leave listen to me right now okay mm-hmm
I asked them already mm-hmm
to add two weeks ago are you guys gonna
put billboards up again for the second
season you guys got a second season yeah
unbelievable
no I'm hopeful I'm definitely hopefully
you guys get a third season I mean I
rate our ratings were very good were
they really and we won our time slot
every [ __ ] week against two though
I'm not against American Ninja Warrior I
know but we're shooting your arch
nemesis show that you should try to be
on against the most your countrymen are
on and you're out here [ __ ] around
acting well for so have you ever seen
American Ninja Warrior I've seen every
episode I've never seen a single Asian
person on that it's always white dude no
the last episode they bring in Asians to
show em what it's really all they do
they've been in real ninjas dude you
wanna talk about internment camps dude
go to American is worried during the day
when they're taping they have those guys
it's like this little pit of [ __ ]
[ __ ] know they're all there eating
oranges and [ __ ] putting lime in each
other's eyes you know it's [ __ ]
worried about him marbles off of each
other's [ __ ] heads it's great make
[ __ ] up it's not uh you're next Matt
Iseman right now really you've been to
the set of American Ninja Warrior yeah
and watch the [ __ ] Asians in the pit
eating oranges yes
that's un-fuckin'-believable I've been
there and I've been to Vietnam and I've
seen [ __ ] Desmond Tutu speak and I've
seen Fidel Castro speak that's
unbelievable man okay yeah I've been all
this [ __ ] dude I saw a kid who [ __ ]
fell on a wishing well and who knows
where he is
you know okay I just want to let you
guys know that uh
sometimes you want to have something on
your body that
you know you want to swim but you also
want to be on the land you know and that
for me has become bird dogs shorts and
bird dogs
I mean look sometimes your bird you know
needs to be kind of dog down in some
shorts and that's what they are they're
gym shorts they're gym shorts but with a
built in silky soft soft soft e inner
liner so you don't have to wear
underwear because think about this
putting on underwear then putting on
shorts over them and the underwear in
the shorts maybe don't even know each
other they've never met that's insane
now with bird dogs it's just one thing
it's that it's that one-stop shop for
your crotch and for your buttocks and
for the top of your legs and it's
beautiful man look you can put a pair on
put them on on Friday take them off
Monday morning before work that's what
I've been doing I mean they're so
drunken comfortable it feels like it it
feels like honestly feels like somebody
with really really soft hands is holding
all your junk and also cares about you
and those are bird dogs okay nobody
likes a guy that wears underwear so quit
doing it go to bird dogs calm and enter
promo code Vaughn for 10% off your order
this is the deal of a lifetime the
shorts are sick that's bird dogs calm
you will not take these things off and
if you don't I won't judge you if you
show up in some regular stinky shorts
yes you're done with me but you show up
in them dirty bird dogs hey we still
friends so in Shanghai after you do this
show did you go hang out somewhere else
I went hung out yeah man I'll say this
super-safe China I mean the area I was
in Shanghai that place is super safe man
yeah people everybody's just worried
about throwing [ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ]
about what's going on with you you know
yeah they were kind of curious I got see
people looking but if I looked over they
would look away like it was like they
didn't want to be rude
you know yet at the same time you'd have
a dude I saw a guy pick his nose feed it
to a cat I know which is [ __ ] most
beautiful thing I've ever seen China
oh it's China [ __ ] my bad yeah yeah yeah
that's right yeah you pop a zit in China
some other guy catches that in his mouth
oh yeah yeah
animals no I'm not saying that nothing
is wasted in China right that's what it
is yeah some guy you know what they love
their huh you I don't know if you do
that just take she wants she want some
gum yeah just put it on the street
oh wow yeah I didn't know that do that I
saw anyone going to Shanghai or jig chew
some gum just spit on the street
Wow they love it I thought they seemed
like if you if some guys spit another
guy [ __ ] it some guys sprout up a bus
window another guy catching no no you
know you know what that's from right ah
some kid American did that about 25
years ago really and he got beat by that
like oh wait I remember they remember
that from growing up yeah there's a mom
yeah who was that boy I give look it up
man this guy got a beat they came to me
yeah - almost done in his name at cane
or something it was his name yeah look
at her Herman Cain dudes and the
politician Herman Cain remember him bro
I was yeah he owned little sea oh yeah
you did yeah can you believe Herman
[ __ ] cocaine I owned
Little Caesars dude in I was voting for
Herman Cain til the end of time bro and
I thought that's not it that's not it
white guy throwing gun kid a kids threw
gun Singapore Singapore Singapore not
Shanghai that wasn't something I thought
when you were talking about the gun yes
Singapore yeah yeah
not throwing gum why I came to Singapore
yeah um because of chewing gum though
right I don't know what he did look at a
teenager Kings were terrible and this
vandalism was his name I wasn't chewing
ago Michael Fay
there's no cane in that room Michael Fay
cane so we got that we got it wrong
Michael I got it wrong my god Michael K
dude [ __ ] him bro that's what he gets
over there if you [ __ ] around I don't
[ __ ] around in other countries do when
I'm there I look people in the [ __ ]
eyes I'm honorable I eat breakfast I
[ __ ] take a nap
dude you took took huh took to
masturbation no no that's not you what
no Duke took is not masturbation jook
jook
yeah you know Chuck took this huh I'm
gonna tell you what it is okay it's an
old it's a Korean slang okay and Juke
took means [ __ ] oh wow and and I've
asked people in Korea
why'd you choke and they said oh that's
what it sound like oh yeah like to to
write and whenever I go to a foreign
country I always took to you do well not
before my girlfriend but I have I [ __ ]
here on the homeland dude you don't paid
you pay huh have you ever paid for it
pay for sex I've paid for escorts and
stuff you used to pay for escorts that
you guys do it
who's that you guys I heard the who told
me there was a group you guys used to go
somewhere in jail we used to do out in
the Pasadena Oxnard or something no we
used to well we were done we've done
different voyages yeah we used to what
does that like you guys get a camper
what do you do
no no I would well I would I can't take
it say the name cuz they're all big
comics not okay and put males or females
dudes okay so I'll just kind of see the
first name do you think I'll get in
trouble for that no or they are they
white guys they'll be fine
yeah so Chris used to call me yeah and
Chris would be like yo man let's do
lunch run this we used to call it lunch
run yeah yeah you know what
yeah but we would say it's lunch runs
okay like we're getting lunch oh we
would never eat that we never eat we
would never know so you don't need bro
you know who ate at 1:00 Jason Keller
Nate at a whorehouse one oh yeah yeah I
learn bro you're paying eats and Percy
down there until on when I came to LA
though Zayn we used to take a bus and it
was like John cap a bunch of people yeah
I think crew Freddie low yeah I'm just
pretty low died no Freddie you know he's
not dead no right Oh pretty low you're
Freddie love little slice so this was a
diverse group and we should go down
there and we used to go to Adelita yeah
in Tijuana hmm and this is back in the
late 90s and so but then was it like fun
of college right you guys were like wow
this is so fun yeah until one day John
cap got attacked down there I could see
that yeah you got physically attacked I
got attacked at The Comedy Store
apparently he's Detective where I don't
know kept role that much but I didn't
say kept role
I just said John Kerr right John cat
yeah yeah and uh so but now what about
this so what was that experience was
like
but what was he would you guys go down
there and go dancing was it more of a
like a romantic time back then
well yeah we would hold hands or
something no like I feel like you know
there was a time where you know engaging
with prostitutes and that sort of thing
was more about well they're set up
they're set up but if you've ever been
to Adelita or Chicago club or Hong Kong
cafe or any of those place I've never
been in any of the hot spots really you
know yeah I was the chat was the lazy
dude was just doing it off a back page
and like scared it as a part Rui Rui Rui
right except an Amsterdam one time I
went yeah we you'd go down there and
there is dance it's it's set up like
nightclubs right so it's like there's
music and I do some dancing because I
can dance yeah yeah I got some moves but
but it's not ballroom dances hi no it's
not no it's up to 50 oh yeah okay
they're being like elegant no it's not
elegant at all you know they play
Rihanna [ __ ] like that right and then
you're like you're dancing to Rihanna
right or back then like informally yeah
back then it was like yeah info so
you're dancing the important then you
know and then a girl goes nice term
Easter thought you would hear a lot
mister mister
boom boom mister you know excuse me boom
boom Easter and okay how much it boom
boom for sex
$60 oh and you could use the can talk
them down to 40 back then oh and then
you should be $40 it's a lot of money I
guess when you're poor comment 61 give
them six years no poor 40 I'm an open
mic to their mics open to the whole
[ __ ] world I understand if I'm not
making a lot of money now 60 yeah now 60
with a $5 tip 65 did Wow Wow that's
pretty good that's good generous and a
lot of them would pay to [ __ ] you now I
bet no no no I do nobody wants to fight
you have some fans I pay to watch you
[ __ ] somebody for a couple minutes you
would it be funny it would you laughs I
think you will here's what I would do
yeah I would probably order a coffee or
something
yeah do I but during it like I'd watch
but it also be like yeah I'm one just
like a medium with almond milk please
and then you know so that way I'm
watching and I'm cheering you on it like
the World Cup a little bit this is dude
named Mike Burton he's a comment uh-huh
and we did this get him Burton's son
isn't it no it's not Tim Burton's son
he's sure
I don't know but Mike Burton oh wait I
[ __ ] know I've hurt you know my boy
yeah it's more like little and I would
be like a juvie yeah Krav Maga
Rai Rai wrestling he do one time he put
his own self in a headlock and yeah that
dude yeah and I'm just yeah I did agree
with that dude yeah me today it was a
feature a girl I was opening mm-hmm and
he convinced her because she did a bit
about on stage about having a threesome
so afterwards my Burton cuz it would you
have one with me and Bob stick okay we
go to the hotel room right now and are
you nervous or something no I mean I
couldn't believe it right I couldn't
believe what that he would include me
and y'all are the same height I know
it's cute yeah it is very cute affair
and but I see him being like aggressive
and wanting to win the threesome that's
always I thought I can do it and you
know what I'm happy that you be that guy
yeah to be like on the outs I'm happy to
lose the threesome what do you mean I'd
like to do it but also like I don't need
to come in first place there's always to
do that he's coming for a second for
sure yeah I'm like the tag team guy yeah
right you go do your thing
Yeah right there's a hero then you come
in and take a whole body saw him you be
the head chef right you'd be that job
Alva do I'll do desserts
that's one that's my thing right so he's
we get naked uh-huh and they both just
start cackling oh wow with laughter when
they see my body huh but yeah I'm
laughing too right but I did it anyway
but the whole time why you'd never you'd
seen your body before they've never seen
my body though right what are you
laughing at cuz they're laughing at my
body okay they're laughing so hard it
makes me want to laugh I think you know
waiting your whole life to see your body
and this is when you decided to do it no
I had seen my body do have mirrors yeah
but you could also not see your body if
you want like I'll go sometimes you know
armor once I went like eight months
my legs I understand that but what I'm
saying to you right now is that I don't
think even cavemen back in the day
yeah where they didn't have mirrors and
they weren't that bright they've seen
their own legs at least yeah
and they've even looked inside a pond
and seen the reflection of their face
yes there's no one on the face of this
planet that has an IQ over 50 that's
never seen it right they've all seen
their bodies on their faces what you're
saying is I'm a dick you think everybody
everyone that's ever lived on the face
of the planet you're saying that because
you experienced no no I'm saying that
what I'm saying that is if you're a baby
right you don't know what a circle is
right right you don't you know you like
even like a triangle you're turning in
your head what is that right that's one
thing but if you're over the age of five
let's just say anyone over the age of
five over the IQ of 50 they've all seen
their bodies in their faces yeah over
the age of 50 but you guys no no no 50
um IQ I'm in oh I don't know if that has
anything to do with it I think if you're
around long enough you get to see your
full body and what they don't know that
then I wouldn't argument though I'm not
arguing about this at all I was just
saying for eight months I decided not to
see look at my own lake hydrant that's
all I was saying yeah and I did it and
it's a new experience you're like oh
[ __ ] when you finally reveal your own
legs to you it's a so you did that to
your while you take a diet it's like a V
yeah I did that with I was a vegetarian
for a month yeah there you go same thing
it's not this I was like a leg Italian
dude you're like a terrier yeah but
anyway is your [ __ ] story man I don't
even know what I was talking about I was
at the strip club they laughed at your
body yeah yeah no way so we were
cackling but you know she would be
blowing him and I would be down eating
her out oh wow really yeah yeah at the
same time we would be our you're getting
second Oh if she's blowing it
you're eating her if she never blew it
you're waiting her out you're getting
secondhand I'm doing all the groundwork
still no riot it's like you oh you like
like a centipede kind of a yeah yeah
like a centipede kind of thing oh well
you know I've been against things dude
bro that's like holding somebody's dick
wow they're like if you hold on to some
guy's nuts while he's [ __ ] another
dude we're home
that's being gay no that's called like
Rosie like it's a it has like a crazy it
has like a name Oh like a sexual name
yeah it's like Sigma it's not now what
is it it's like a celebrity nickname you
know this you know those like Nick know
those little moves that people make up
as a joke yeah like the dirty sanchez
yeah you stick your finger in the girl
and then you give her my address right
and it's how you get pinkeye - that's
how you get pinkeye for sure yeah but
that's not something that people do
though no it's all made like a plumpy
yeah Blum pees pooping and also getting
a blow job at the same time right yes
and that's one that's never happened no
and that's all so disgusting happens in
Cancun a lot though yeah music festivals
yes oh so it has happened before yeah
Oh what about the paranormal have heard
of that one
oh that's when ya know would tell me
well your that's when somebody's blown
you but you go outside and wave Adam or
something no it's basically your [ __ ]
a girl from behind and you kind of get
out you have your friend take over
didn't Amy Schumer use this in a she did
and a closer what was that with it
that's some controversial closure she
had but Patrice O'Neal and used it I
think well yeah but that's not even it
but that's like a street it's internet
joke yeah it's an Internet joke I'm
saying oh that's back when they were
given Amy Schumer money just stand
around you know that's another thing and
I want to say this and I'm not being
bitter I'm not being bitter I'm gonna
say something and has nothing to do with
her I like her
yeah nice lady but when does that happen
for me yeah I'd be talking about that oh
I think it for some people the industry
dislike forces a thing yeah I've never
been forced I I've always been like on
the outside yeah and I have to like
drill in just take your little piece but
that's why you're a great comic man yeah
but I want a free
but a lot of these people like would Amy
Schumer even be able to do a our special
she wants be a politician I don't think
she's even I don't because you'd beyond
it now all right I don't want to be
beyond comedy that's message I saw just
a handler like you know what are you
gonna water skiing
what are you when they do in the boat
water skiing yeah if she's like you know
and then she's the dog later at the lake
yeah Wow
but Chelsea Handler's not funny though
no no nobody thinks I did that who
thinks she's chosen you do yeah you know
really she's not cool but she was she
was okay mom I know but thithi can i I
just wanna let you know yeah that isn't
that the goal though I don't think so
but so you want to struggle the whole
time no I'm not gonna struggle but I
don't need to be greedy I don't need to
get to a certain level of wealth to make
me feel like I'm a certain level yeah
sure that's healthy yeah that's me too
you know me too but do you believe that
like I don't know I be I know I'm gonna
be okay no luck cuz I'm but I'm gonna be
okay so here's the thing yeah it I've
been in the business for over 20 years
yeah and I've worked I have I been on
shows you've been on a ton of shows that
have not done well - that's what I'm say
he's just say I was about and great
shows never been in a great show MADtv
was a great job when you were on it that
reboot was [ __ ] horrible so did you
see that [ __ ] thing on that Jesus he
saw it yes piece of [ __ ] yeah what it
was because of the budget was it though
I'm trying to be like you know diplomat
diplomat about but let's just be I mean
it was not [ __ ] good I mean a mere K
was pretty good on these you know I
can't I'm wearing was on ER he was good
I'm ready does good but it looks like a
lot of it's the same character I mean I
just feel like they could do they could
have really gotten some they just went
for diversity it was just like it was a
cheat it wasn't really based on talented
[ __ ] character people yeah yeah yeah
you know if you want some real
characters go get some [ __ ]
characters man you know yeah you [ __ ]
dombarris get those [ __ ] Goonies
performing up there on Monday night one
of them is a sailor and one guy thinks
he's a [ __ ] battleship or like
homeless people with
but that guy thinks he's been on a
battleship get that kinda get that black
dude that where's that Coonskin cap
every night yeah yeah boy [ __ ] dirty
Stephen Turner that [ __ ] dude showing
up in a [ __ ] raccoon that's a shame
you see but that's a character get a
[ __ ] character's name and do anything
but that but that's it lead add
character I'll follow four [ __ ] five
foot lives right sacred way I've got
pretending he's a [ __ ] chubby Italian
waiter like that you know in every skit
or whatever believable see that you know
or jovian give me a mere K [ __ ]
Burton like he's the ghost of Michael
Landon rah watch Adam for a million
years right just a lot there was a lack
of creativity I thought with it yeah and
it didn't do well I think that's the
obviousness of it it didn't [ __ ] do
nobody gave a [ __ ] about it yeah nobody
gave a [ __ ] about MADtv at the time
though whatever it's only you guys have
to like Old MacDonald that guy was
[ __ ] good you play the wedding planner
when I am peel yeah yeah key and Peele
like paranal it's a lot of good guys you
know but there was some dudes on there
there were [ __ ] straight killers yeah
you know but at the time when we were
doing it like I used to drive down
Sunset Boulevard because Jordan Peele
didn't have a car right for the five
years I worked with him right but so you
knew that if we were in the sketch
together that he would be walking down
the street and I had to pick him up and
he'd be just kind of you know walking
down the street with his hand his pocket
and he and at the time we would just be
you know we would just be hanging out
going oh this doesn't feel like we're
doing it they're not saying no one gives
a [ __ ]
but people cared and nobody in our heads
and what we what we were know because we
saw that virtually you weren't doing
well it's what you're saying everything
it didn't feel like a show man and only
in later when after you know Will Sasso
everyone laughed and we all did our own
thing
and then we got respect okay yeah it was
but while we were on it we didn't get
any no [ __ ] respect really no dude I
mean you should I would go on line and
people would rip me apart see that you
know like pee you fat ugly piece you're
not Talent I mean on and on
and this is what the internet was new
yeah you took it personally oh you need
to know what a troll was yeah right so
they're coming a friend
you thought it was like your neighbor or
someone that you knew and then you were
like I should I kill my song yeah there
was this thing called MADtv Planet MADtv
mmm he was out of Canada and it was a
forum and they had like a page with me I
liked but it was 12 pages of just
strictly he's not funny right and it was
brutal Vaughn [ __ ] yeah
you orange Gobstopper [ __ ] like that
yeah dude and an asian kid in a play one
time at our school it wasn't really
Asian but they is okay they painted him
orange dude wait wait you guys did like
platoon but like yeah platoon but like
its height over Nutcracker it was enough
sweet sounds like Willy Wonka yes and
Drosselmeyer was Asian they wanted
somebody yeah there been like an uproar
or something or somebody just bombed a
different country and they wanted to do
like a tribute or something send me one
of the drosselmeier Asians no yeah Wow
this was like and uh and they didn't
yeah they painted him orange and put
like big like dark hair on him really I
thought it was really sweet actually
because here's the thing a lot of times
it's the intention like what's the
intention like if somebody meant well
then that's their intention you know
it's like your intention was good and if
you're a good person you can recognize
that I think most a lot of what goes on
these days is an intention it's like
just you know it's a lot of this like
fake like oh this is it's just a media
telling you something's bad or telling
you this or like it's like people being
racist on Twitter it's like you're not
[ __ ] when I was young you to really
be racist you know what I'm saying yeah
when I was young they had real racist
people they had real white people that
didn't like black people and real black
people it didn't wipe like white people
need to get out there and [ __ ] prove
it you know I'm saying get out there and
beat somebody's ass if you're racing
now you're just tweeting and you're
considered racist and [ __ ] put Rodney
King oh yeah that was like on tape right
get out there you know tell you yeah
yeah
Reginald any rile prove your work prove
your [ __ ] words now you're
we eating in you're racist you're a
[ __ ] yeah you see the n-word a couple
of times it's like come on let's back it
up and say it what I took it to next
level yeah website back it up I mean now
what would like a Swiss Army knife or
whatever yeah but I'm just saying back
then you had to like get out there and
actually call somebody and that's what
I'm saying yeah that's what I'm saying
you had to actually be racing yeah yeah
now it's just you can sit in your home
somewhere and still like oh these
[ __ ] hongki's and you're a racist nah
man I didn't do it when I was in middle
school I was in The Sound of Music
yeah and I played you fight honor - I
know - McHale a dude one of the kids you
did yeah I played Kurt Oh
the middle kid I guess yeah so there's a
scene where Fraulein Maria is
introducing you know us to the dude oh
no we're getting introduced to Fraulein
Maria yeah
we're coming down the stairs and when
I'm coming down the stairs we did like
12 shows hmm every time I would come
downstairs the whole audience would do a
laugh applause break because it was so
funny that I was like the Asian guy in
the middle
hmm every time I go I'm Kurt I'm well 12
or whatever the line is people were gone
and laughs so I remember going to the
director hey um is there any way you can
change the lines what a [ __ ] and
they're like me yeah
no you have to justify it where each I'm
Kurt I'm adopted just so that you know
but you're making them laugh you're a
comedian you know at the time I didn't
want to be a comedian I was trying to be
a serious actor in this a serious
actress is an Asian and Sound of Music
get your [ __ ] life together directors
fault eh you're a [ __ ] idiot what's
their fault for even casting me is that
what you're saying or not you're trying
to [ __ ] play a white kid in war-torn
Germany you want them to change the
lines just justify why would there be
out of all these kids yeah the middle
kid is Asian don't you think that's
weird watching a play like that this is
the exact it this is the problem this is
California's issue right now it's like
California one to every
to [ __ ] explain like we need to
change the director like look director
we've got a problem like you know one of
the children in one of the Von Trapps is
Asian and they don't feel really good
when they come down the stairs because
people are laughing yeah because you're
a [ __ ] Asian and von trapp okay okay
I get what you're saying right you can't
change the whole [ __ ] thing it's like
a black Annie you can't have a black
that is like you can't have Kathy
Griffin play [ __ ] I understand it but in
black Annie but in black Annie right she
was still black in the show right right
she wasn't pretending to be actual white
Annie right me but no I had to be I had
to be white Kurt oh I see that's what
I'm saying right if it was like oh if it
was an all-asian cast and it wasn't in
Germany but it was now in Singapore
right then you wouldn't have to do it I
see we're saying right but it's like
when you're watching white Sound of
Music and you see one Asian kid you have
to change the lines of it yeah and good
this is Kurt like the dad going this is
Kurt he stand out in the Sun too long
okay just one line right and it changes
the whole and everything that we can
continue the story and it all makes
sense right makes sense I see what
you're saying yeah he likes to run into
walls that's what his face is [ __ ]
flat right and they go okay let's move
on damn dude right he's [ __ ]
he's a [ __ ] but dude it is crazy I
bet a lot of people that have
deficiencies and stuff like that
what do you mean immediately think
you're their guy you know like I can see
somebody was like a vitamin deficiency
or like severe you know DNA deficiency
or something immediately being like a
chromosome deficiency being like oh this
is our guy you know this is our mayor
you know this is our Wizard of Oz you
know like oh my god no guy but I want to
say that what about you know the guy can
I just say this guy yeah it's your tone
man is it really yes it has your tone
dude yeah yeah man that's it my bad
let me say this I remember there was a
time
when they had I remember they had a
group in our town called White's against
Mexicans right and they didn't have any
Mexican wham wam yeah yeah yeah really
we didn't have any Mexicans right yeah
so basically was just people wasting gas
money really yeah yeah for Mexicans you
know that store you see on stage and not
having any that stood that story that
you see on stage about there was one
Asian kid that you had over a rumor
there a rumor and then you went to that
area that Slidell Louisiana yeah right
to see him and he wasn't there he wasn't
there we saved up money it cost us 60 I
know but is that true does your story
yeah there's no way that's true oh let
me ask you this let me ask you this
though okay
why why why would you give a fake okay
I'm just saying in my liberation right
what imagine you're fully Asian now I am
100% yeah but like 40 like I feel like
20% of you is a [ __ ] white dude who
might have a black stepdad right right
but there is a so imagine you were a
hundred percent Asian right like living
in a [ __ ] place like just honoring
your parents all day and just like all
you can hear is your parents yelling at
you in your head about how you know you
did something wrong I got a prot like a
test question wrong when you were seven
right you're a fully Asian you know and
you're eating like you're barely eating
like you're eating small vegetables and
like basically vegetables you would only
see on like Super Mario World
- right like you're eating like small
carrots small pieces of corn small
radishes right it's because I'm small
huh no your regular oh my god you're
just kimchi to the max right Kim cheetah
and so you're eating out of small dishes
and mine there's not even any midnight
snacks just to wake up in the middle of
the night and just wish that God had
filled your stomach right and pray yeah
so you're a hut you're so age and you
can't even [ __ ] really what he things
we do yeah by the way so here's what
happens though um
you yeah [ __ ] I forgot what the story
was about is about imagine him being
Asian and then have never seen a white
person yes so now you hear you've never
seen a white person right before okay
okay like you've seen dances of
right but no you haven't seen it you've
just read the script I read the script
of dances over the world right so you
that's all Union the only description
was the Kevin Costner character right
right so imagine now that you hear
there's a white guy over the hill up two
hills away well I never thought of it
that way so what you're saying now is is
that you're an area with just whites
yeah you're eating whites and black
you're eating your big vegetables yes
the normal sized vegetable bread rerai
right we're just a normal what you're
dancing at a good time yeah and all of
us you hear the like the ungodly rumor
that there is a Asian guy in the next
sent over didn't know there's a dream
and a snake whispers it to me right okay
so you see her on e yeah and then you
saved the money yeah we cut grass me and
two of my boys with right
we cut grass to go see this rumored
Asian all right and you never saw him
again
well here's what it was it was a Pizza
Hut it burned down right and the roof
member out Pete's I'd have this crazy
roofs roofs people had never seen before
and I'm talking about or not yeah I do
yeah and the roof was on the ground whoa
and so somewhere along the lines people
maybe somebody saw somebody come out of
the sword or something and they you know
their hair was darker or something yeah
who knows and maybe you know somehow
somebody's like yeah there's a there's
an Asian person that lives there ah
it was a it wasn't even true so we went
to see it it wasn't true maybe it was
the kid who played it in the play and he
was just practicing yeah it could have
been I mean I don't know what it was
what would you remember the first time
you saw an actual Asian though yeah when
I think it was there was an episode of
highway to heaven actually with Michael
Lane and a victor friend you love
Michael well most of America does so
this is why you're disconnected but um
he they had an Asian boy on there and I
think they picked him up he was a
hitchhiker and they picked him up and
dropped him off in a different town
there's no way can you look that up
please if there's an episode and up you
know if there was an episode of what's
the story show called highway to heaven
highway to heaven and
there was an Asian boys hitchhiking
probably the 60 or 70 most popular shows
I've never even heard of it and that's
the truth really Victor Prince won an
Academy Award okay also Merlin Olsen was
one of the he was in one of the episodes
yeah um so yeah I can't believe Brynn
and she'll try to bang your girlfriend
dude that's crazy I said that you
mentioned that no I didn't say that I'm
just saying that there is you know in my
head there is that fear right well you
think he would um I think that if and
this iodide or if we broke up that he
would what if you just got really sick
for like a week like I was in a coma if
I I could see that well my but you woke
up to piss yeah but I was like a
sleeping coma like walking around call
mom no no in the bed como but you get up
to peace you know buddy I'm not in a
coma then there's no coma like that
there could be okay let's say I have
this weird disease where I have a I'm in
a coma Becca P yeah and and if I think
if they call the yellow sleep they call
it they've had the yellow sleep yeah
yeah yeah and it's just kind of peeing
not because you're Asian I'm just saying
yeah I know but I don't know but what
I'm saying though is but you just think
oh I just want to say this is that
just don't say yellow sleep again they
call it the Kung Pao coma
is that it he doesn't look like a
hitchhiker but there is one year isn't
boy I do that hitchhiking dude but he's
hitchhiking on a plane look at him oh
that is oh my god yeah he's a Laotian I
think yeah and look he's a man that
adopts him he's very slow people he
doesn't love him at first oh he doesn't
mm-hmm season 3 episode 4 oh it's a good
one oh it's so good and look at his
mother's that
that's uh what's his name the guy who's
in La Bamba Ritchie pallid where was
though oh I know um what's is that
actor's name don't even say it
but do you know his name yeah Lou
Diamond Phillips who's that Lou Diamond
Phillips pull it back on it's not that
was I swear to god that was a little
done with Holmes I think it was young
Lou Diamond it wasn't even any it's a
quick flash you can barely see him yeah
there yeah yeah that's okay I mean
that's on him that's the guy I that's
you think the mother is played by Lou
down with olbes he thought he'd be a
pretty woman oh well here's the funny
thing about Lou Diamond Phillips
he gets cast in every Mexican thing like
every Mexican role he's not next in his
Native American
he's also been given an honorary key to
Mexico right yes not even [ __ ]
Mexican really I've met him before a
couple times he's amazing really one of
the nicest guys I've ever met right yeah
you know also I've met before Ralph
Macchio yeah one of the nicest guys I've
ever met and Ralph Macchio created a
reality show that people don't know
about executive produced something is
called American it might have been
American justice or something it was one
of the best shows ever I can't believe
it didn't deserve it a celebrity will
you meant from the past or you know in
your present moment mm-hmm that was a
complete and utter douchebag I mean have
you worked with anybody that was a
douchebag
that was a douchebag like somebody was
like Eisen Rich Eisen is a sportscaster
and I worked with him one time and he
was just he's just an ass he's an ass
yeah yeah he just yeah and I could yeah
and this was just my perception yeah I
just thought he was always an ass ah
didn't get like look we're all part-time
asses yeah but he seemed like he Etta
you know what my person is yet a
full-time I didn't control chemica Trel
yeah who is that she's like Sex in the
City
oh and it's one before what really it
was a shuttle outside of that it was
Chelsea Handler she was the only person
I was ever on that didn't even say hello
all you did Chelsea Lately yeah she
didn't say hello you say hello we what
she just acted like yes she was just uh
ass you know yeah you know what that's
her persona though
yeah but she's also now become a lonely
woman that yells at people on Twitter
you know yeah it's like I know that's
what you end up man he's so funny when
you say that no children she has no
husband it she has no family but that
but when you say it's so funny because
when you say that yeah in my head I see
because I was on Chelsea so much right
and because I was always kind of scared
of her
yeah that way even when you're talking
now I get a little scared yeah and that
weird like when you're saying that I'm
like oh my god
is she listening you know yeah but it's
like I could just say [ __ ] it right well
she also talked about like she tweets
about like diversity and this and that
but all of her staff was white I mean
she had like now she had white guests on
the show she had diverse guests on the
show and comedians but her staff was all
Y up if you look at all like even
writers in general like I mean the
writers from my show they're all white
right they're either gay or white no I
think it is because here's here's my
argument against that though is is that
how many like for me it's like how many
Asian writers are there a lot bro you
tell everyone know I I know there's a
lot of Asians but there's probably no
Asian NASCAR drivers you're sort of
saying it's what they choose to do if
you say all right that's a good point
nurses yeah there's a lot of Filipino
nurses great no choose it right they're
the best right what is that tayo Miata
Larson would beg to differ he's a half
asian that doesn't have locations
yeah it doesn't count but here's what
he's a Keanu Reeves of loud now yeah
yeah does a car that's like saying that
Erik's Palestra is an Asian basketball
coach right right coach for the Miami
Heat right that dude ain't [ __ ] Asian
bro
like he might be Asian like on paper
yeah but I'm talking about that's paper
mache when you see Steve Byrne do you
see Asian or no I see some guy that's
kind of trapped in something else
you know yeah yeah I see an Asian but
it's kind of like a Mount Rushmore Asian
like he's hidden in the rock wall yeah
that's what I see to me and I almost see
like sometimes I'm like damn Steve must
feel like he can't really you know is it
tough to find a lane because he's in oh
my god that would be a very difficult
land to be in you know unless he had
some eyeliner yeah if I was half asian I
wouldn't have like little a bottle of
yellow makeup mm-hmm and a little
eyeliner yeah so that if I needed to do
it up a little bit I would do it up oh I
thought about sealing my eyes and even
more and going Asian really you had to
get work I thought about everything in
this town yeah but you're killing it
dude I'm doing okay and it's been 15
years right and it's only because it's I
don't know what it no no I'm gonna tell
you right now and this is the honest
truth I don't drive to Century City for
losers yeah you know I honestly when my
producer said you're gonna do Theo's
tomorrow he said it to me yesterday
oh yeah and I go oh finally it wasn't
like oh I gotta go right it was like Oh
finally this piece of [ __ ] you know is
getting me on his [ __ ] show Yeah
right it's so well he's why I'm like
that
I felt like you wouldn't want to come I
mean I did I did you're [ __ ] stupid
Comedy Central show yeah I mean was
great I mean I know that I guess I I
don't know I guess I just felt no no I
feel nervous about asking some people
you know for sure why me though I'm your
friend yeah I dunno know what double
yeah oh yeah right yeah I guess I don't
know sometimes I feel nervous about
asking people for stuff you know I get
that way too
like for instance my podcast hmm there's
certain people that I know like Jenna
Fischer is on my show mm-hmm and I've
had everyone else on the show but I'm
afraid to ask her Jenna Fischer from
Saturn out loud from the office she's on
your TV show she's on my TV she's on a
breakable Kimmy Schmidt isn't she no
she's on splitting up together the show
I'm on mmm-hmm I haven't seen that I
know you haven't heard it's not that
good but I'm gonna check it out you
don't have to watch it huh
you don't have to watch it I'm no I
don't have to I don't want to see you
know
that's it I saw you in love though and I
thought you did a good job I don't need
it
whatever you're doing right now I don't
need it you're right I know I know what
I do I'm pandering
not that you're pandering is not it I
don't really I don't really bear I don't
believe know that I don't blame her and
it's not like I'm not pandering yeah
yeah I'm pandering yeah but when I'm
saying I we're pandering and I just
[ __ ] showed you a picture of a panda
bear yeah but you would like it though
why do I like them what why do you like
pandas honestly when there's so many
other bears be honest do you know why I
know why why cuz they look like you guys
know they honestly I think people like
pandas because they look like they've
been abused they have two black eyes
yeah yeah and I feel like they you know
they seem sad and pitiful in that way
they're also not dangerous looking right
right when you see raccoons look like
burglars though yeah and I don't hang
out with them yeah I don't know when
they look like they're in disguises you
ever notice that about a wreck yeah this
song they do ya know what that is yeah
you're all pretending they're not
raccoons I know it's like oh you're just
a little bear that's in the trash no
you're a raccoon
yeah Riya riot but even when you did
this I knew what they look like yeah
you didn't have to do that yeah I know
both cool dude how would you feel if I
got a picture of you like this
commissioned and I had Brady Mathews
who's that I know that's Chris Farley oh
it is mm-hmm who did that
Brady Matthews the comedian it wouldn't
be cool to ever want to Bobbie Louie
we were I'm sorry the comedian Brady
math uses an artist great artist yeah he
is yeah this was his first one he ever
did well is that what he's been doing
lately good haven't seen him around
yeah I haven't see him in a while he's
just painting now he does great
impressions he does great voices ya know
he's open for me before yeah I like him
a lot I love Brady uh but yeah he does
painting can we just go back to you
though real quick though it says how
well you're doing I think yeah I think
on street level I mean first of all
you're the most sawed-off sought after
guests for podcasts yeah why is that I
don't know you guys haven't asked me
back in about a year you're doing it in
two weeks
oh I am all right I know that
I say this we've only we've never had
repeat casts that's not true delese been
on there a couple times one time plus
how many times no just one how many
fingers you Oval number now one i won
you snuck five in there first
who else have you had Stevie that's my
brother
yeah my brother's been on three times I
don't care okay
okay who else the only time we've had
repeated officer care losses the best
guess though officers great and I don't
blame you yeah yeah and if you guys ever
hooked up be honest dude I gave you and
I can't even watch this her porn really
yeah she was showing me a scene once a
couple years ago and there was like
three dicks in her mouth hmm
and I went I can't cuz it's too much
weight to two two tops who's a lot yeah
but two is fine one is three it's like
you know penises are touching dude right
why the guy's not into it one guy's like
I'm not gonna hang it at the mouth I'm
in the middle broke three is I imagine
three dates right and the middle dick he
has two dicks like they like a sandwich
right and the mouth parts not even
touching or his dick threes like the tie
cave it's like somebody's people
distract you know yeah his little soccer
you know yeah no but you know I knew I
saw did you know this so if you don't
know I'll say Akira is a porn star yeah
anyone listening and she's one like the
best best yeah and she's also a great
she's great to be around
I love talking with her I do - she's a
funny she was at the store the other day
he hangs out the store she's great but I
knew I saw when she was in high school
hmm you know that mm-hmm so when the
last San Diego no in the Laugh Factory
when it used to be in New York Laugh
Factory
so when Jamie Masada first opened it
this is like years ago 14 years ago hmm
he called me the day buddy
can you do the you know my room I fly
about so I flew he flew me out there and
he goes no one bought tickets for your
show so I said okay and he goes I want
you to pass out flyers no yeah okay
and he goes on but this is the girl and
it was a junior she was into a junior in
high school
Wow
also Kyra and she was just a kid and we
passed flyers all day did you try to hit
on her no no she was a kid yeah I
wouldn't have yeah she looked like a kid
yeah she little titties and everything
you know man
oh man that's weird so that made this
extremely weird no no I mean she had
small breasts yeah a kid had him I don't
see breasts on kids
and you shouldn't either she didn't have
any good okay there we go
okay all right and we're back we're bad
didn't notice oh she was a child
yeah and she had no hair down there Wow
probs who knows if she did or not but no
huge sore probs what'd you say nothing
go on
so anyway she um and as she goes let's
be Facebook friends like all right so we
you know she would be you'd message each
other on Facebook in every couple years
she would say she goes I'm the number
one down at dominatrix in New York and I
would be like don't do it it's gonna
lead to a you know I would like give her
motherly you'd be a nice guy right then
a year later I'm a stripper Noblet you
know what do you do with your life
you know I'm a porn star and I think I
went oh we're done then Wow
and then years later you know I was
watching on no I was watching some award
show the the AVN Awards oh yeah you know
who watches that people who watch porn
dude I don't watch the [ __ ] okay
I don't watch uh that you know the ESPYs
if I don't I saw it because um Greg
Fitzsimmons was hosting it was he really
yeah huh so in your [ __ ] face
you know I first Danna dart Dana de
Armand in a porn star and I knew he is
she hosted on the carpet one time for a
be in and I saw that and I thought she
was hilarious he was funny yeah very
funny
you know so I saw her on that mm-hmm and
I go oh my god she's doing well like
she's the top if you're a porn star and
you're like you're doing like you know
really get out like people just [ __ ]
on you yeah literally you know and
you're not getting any almonds what if
you're not even [ __ ] it's just you
eating almonds yeah yeah we really but
she's the top of her game
then she was doing a podcast with my
friend David Cho and that Irene Ida with
her and we've been friends ever since
and I'm just very proud of her actually
yeah she's working here in a book she's
not remarried in she should know she's
not married anymore oh but she got
remarried didn't know I don't know are
you still single or you're single or you
with a girl
nope I've been seeing a girl been seeing
a gal I like her so yeah you don't talk
about her huh I can already tell I don't
not I don't I don't talk about it too
much on here right I mean just because
like you know saw a personal life I like
to try and keep yourself you know sure
I'm gonna your girlfriend's on your
podcast
yeah I mean you know I'll be honest with
you it's like it's helped me this is the
first girl that I've ever been with that
I could feel real change in my the other
areas of my love while and all the other
girls and I loved all of them you know
all my girlfriends but they didn't
change they didn't really motivate me
but but kalila motivates me yeah all the
things that I have even the show that I
have I'm on now I I equate it to her yes
because when I first started dating her
I had this policy where I would not
audition she said why don't you audition
I go because I'm terrible at it but is
that true though where do you get a
little lazy no I had real bombs in there
oh wow yeah I would I would panic yeah
oh I do that - I hate and I walk in the
room and just not beyond and just lose
just be scared and then they'd be and
they would say to my agent yeah he's
just terrible he just was all over the
place yeah it hurt me yeah
oh that hurts especially if you're an
actor can you an entertainer yeah yeah
it hurts you but were you an actor first
or were you like you first and then
MADtv and then I did Stan I did The
Tonight Show before I did that today
right so but you were on the stand-up
right you were stand-up so then it's
different getting in acting's totally
different yeah I didn't even know how to
do it yeah I still don't know but like I
would have these bombs and then she was
like you know you're a [ __ ] yeah
because the odds of you getting it
anyway is so slim right you have to try
and so she would
go to the auditions with me one time
this actually happened I had this
audition for this NBC pilot mmm and I
read it I'm like I'm never gonna get
this hmm there's so many lines you know
oh I hate that there was so many lines
and she's like you're a [ __ ] and I go
on feel like you were a [ __ ] or not
yeah it was yeah it was out of fear yeah
so then the next day I wake up and I
sleep in but you sleep in all this time
somebody said you sleep like 17 hours a
day yeah I'm like a pair on hibernate
that's I don't like life so I stopped
and she woke me up and she goes you have
your audition I go I'm not I'm not going
I don't know where I'm not gonna get
it's a waste of time right she'd get in
the [ __ ] car you [ __ ] Wow so we get
in the car and we drive to M beat like
that place where they're doing it oh
yeah and we're in the middle of the
street and she's dragging me about my
shirt into the game okay and I'm gonna
and we gonna fight I go [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] you know me like don't touch me
and I we we literally get in a fight and
she goes you know I can't date a guy
that's like so so much of a [ __ ] and I
go oh I'll go in there I'm gonna fail so
I went in there and it waited like an
hour
I remember seeing Eric Griffin there oh
god and he ruins the vive always right
he's field look he's so angry even
though he has nine jobs right he's
always what I know he's always working
but and I I walked into the room and I
literally didn't say hi to anybody and I
just read it off the page I went I just
read it and you got it but no with that
go mom come home and then I get a call
what was it for Moana no it's not a
Polynesian [ __ ] cartoon [ __ ] crazed
voiceover it was an NBC pilot oh my man
and I I'm testing they said you're
testing for it unbelieva not them that
Monday I got it and then that was it dr.
Pat was Noah Adams no it was a bath
patch mother [ __ ] Adams weren't you
in that what was that thing you were in
Doctor Zhivago or something Doctor
Zhivago that's 1960s [ __ ] well there was
something recent or a few years back
I've been in a bunch of [ __ ] what was
the thing what movie I've been the
budget didn't make it you were a doctor
Oh animal practice yeah animal practice
that was an animal practice no were the
real animals in it yeah you're right
about it yeah no can I talk about this
yeah so I got the show okay a pilot I
didn't get picked up but what am i
boring you
no you know what you're being rude no I
knew it didn't get picked up but go on
[Laughter]
no I'm sorry all right jack talking
about along you know has been a long
life I guess I know I get frustrated
recently why I don't know but finished
restore it was done now why is you
didn't get it I could get it but she but
she loved you for that no moral the
story is that she got me in the right
mind thing is that no matter you gotta
try you got to walk through fear and if
you fail you fail yeah and so I just
started doing it slowly every time now
hmm and then I started booking [ __ ] yeah
and then she taught me a big lesson
that's all I'm saying
yeah that sometimes a girl will motivate
you a partner to go out and do things
and if even if she even if I bombed in a
room she was still there okay so now
then what about this then why is it
sometimes that there's a certain type of
motivation and that sort of thing that
you can only get or only it only comes
if a woman does it you know what I'm
saying
yeah dudes can't do it for him like if a
guy does that for you it doesn't work
but why because she did that does that
work I think a lot of it is is like she
tested my manhood and my ego and I think
that she hit the right spot hmm before
she try to do it philosophically or
spiritually it didn't work for me so
then it got to the point where she was
like you're a [ __ ] right saying that I
live in fear right right and I don't
want to take risks and that was the
right angle for me and it mode it not
only did it to show her to prove my
point
mm-hmm but I failed which is I'm glad I
did right because she was riot and even
little things like usually I before I
met her I wouldn't go out for
guest-starring stuff yeah but she was
like you know love came around right and
then she was like I could chat doesn't
like me
it just in my head I would just say that
even though it's not true yeah in my
alcoholic mind I would come up with
stuff like that
and I went it and I got it and then
because I got that the director were the
directors of the show hmm like you know
I worked with them on love but he did
the sitcom that I'm on now oh wow right
and when he left the show I didn't know
he was going to this ABC show and I got
a call she's like he said this guy just
spoke so highly of you hmm
that you don't even have that audition
they just offered me the part really
yeah like a series regular Wow I should
have been a table read I read it but
that was all because I met him on love
right
but everything leads to another thing
right so now she's opened my eyes up to
like a bunch of stuff like people
hearing me right now thing might think
that I'm [ __ ] right right now but
this this Tiger Burley podcast that I
have
she went to Guitar Center and bought all
the equipment yeah
she set everything up and she's like you
know what I know you don't want to do a
podcast but I'm just gonna do it on my
own well for two weeks she did it on her
own really yeah and then one day I was a
walk by the room and I go [ __ ] I'll do
it so I went in there and I did one and
then I did all of them and then and then
we came up with Tiger Bella in the whole
name but she did that which and now
because of that I'm selling out all over
the place now yeah because of the so
like in many ways you know I'm buying a
house right now in the only way I can
buy a house is because she motivated me
to make more money to get a house and
now I'm actually I found one where are
you gonna live here it's right next to
Melrose is it really gonna live on
Melrose forever it's like literally
right off of it and it's like this
beautiful like Wow so I'm gonna buy I'm
buying it that's where Matt Iseman lives
from who's the host of American Ninja
Warrior fuck'em so you're getting close
to you so if you're listening you know
you know you can have a girl okay even
have a girl that like doesn't die just
as somebody a hole okay so why does a
woman do that why why is it that a from
a woman were able to feel that and make
that change because yeah if a dude tells
you that kind of [ __ ] you don't give a
[ __ ] yeah but in dudes I've never done
that for me right
like Chris Delia's never go hallo will
you you should just constantly get more
of it you know right but a dude also
can't get close enough to us like that
to do us like that you know I got effect
on us you know you know and I'm gonna
say something crazy and I've never seen
really said this before but I don't
think I have any friends like your
friend right yeah but how we yeah we're
friends I know but we're not like best
friends exactly but also in LA it's hard
because we live far away yeah in LA leap
a lot and we're both glad I found a lot
don't blame it on me man but you do
sleep a lot that has nothing to do with
our friendship but a lot of times if you
want to be friends with somebody and
they're asleep it's hard but here's the
thing is is that Theo von right I
honestly just I'm gonna just like hear
me out I honestly believe that you're
gonna be a huge comedy star I think that
your point of view on stage is so weird
and so original and you paint a world
that is obviously a show I can see a TV
show based on your act right now on what
I would [ __ ] get Netflix just to
watch that show yeah all right thanks I
think you're one of the nicest guys
would you play a woman in it yes 100%
um but you I think you're one of the
nicest is in the world and when we when
we're together we're good yeah we're
always you know I feel comfortable
around you but it's like a are you my
friend I guess but you know I think that
I have a lot of acquaintances that I
like but I really friendship is like in
a war I don't know if you'd save me but
I'd come out there and talk to you and
give you water and give you water and
give you sliced pears I know but that's
not the same but who else is out there
nobody like you wouldn't do a Forrest
Gump
koalas banging Brendan brother I'm
outgoing Street I'm out there in the
street with some water and the pair is
there right you're like where's kalila
right right right like Oh who's your
best friend in common he has to work you
know what probably is his MO mandela
thing which is because mo and i were on
this thing of reality bites back a long
time ago which is like a scripted this
comedy series and
and he and I just kind of became like
confidants since then so I know that I
know that he always has like my best
interest but I do know also that I mean
you've been so supportive and I wouldn't
even have an agent if it wasn't for you
don't say that
you know I didn't have one so far it's
so if I manager could even get me an
agent I know but it's so funny that you
say that because it's like when I heard
that you didn't have one yeah it's like
this is gonna be an easy sell because
I've been with its mad yeah for 20-plus
years right
and so I rarely I got you and Eric
Griffin there yeah but those are the
easiest Lobb cells in the world now I
try to get I guess hazers Trail there
yeah he's great he is great but it's a
harder sell right you know he I want to
do some sketches with him you should
he's one of the most I think he's
up-and-coming like he's gonna put up
like a [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying is it's an easy sell you know
I've done you know other things of that
nature and you know you guys are I've
done a two guy I've helped people that
I'm grateful really I'm not gonna name
names I want to so bad but name just a
couple of the name I can't first name no
I can't even do that is it a black guy
or white guy I can't even do that one
girl one guy's black but I've unbeliev
like I've put myself out there I made
the effort
mm-hmm and they don't know it's fine I
don't do it to get the acknowledgment
mm-hmm but it you do get a little it
does kind of you know when you're
driving down the street and you see a
billboard of them mm-hmm and that's how
big some of these guys are and they
forget and you just gotta go
I won't text me back you know right in
your head but that's human nature yeah
is it human nature I mean but no I think
there's a conscious effort and I find
this too sometimes you have to remember
there's you have to make a conscious
effort if you want to stay connected to
yourself and if you don't want to forget
who does the things for you I talked to
a week ago David
salzman who was my boss at MADtv this
old Jew II kind of like mogul you know
and I was sitting there we're hat we're
having coffee
he's the whole guy and he used to he'd
you know he produce Judge Judy all these
he's a
you know you enlarge with Quincy Jones I
mean this guy's been around for a long
time
mm-hmm powerful a lot of money he was I
was telling him about that and he goes
oh that's common and he goes the reason
why that happens is when you help
somebody and then they blow up and then
they don't rent they don't ever
acknowledge your existence
he's because you remind them of what
they were when they were struggling Wow
and so they don't want to be reminded of
that because it's a fear that they'll
either go back to that they don't want
to live like that anymore
hmm so it's just a subconscious thing
where they just kind of go oh yeah I
don't even I won't even acknowledge that
ok so right now then let's go through
another super interesting yeah they
don't want to take themselves back there
they don't want to feel like one over
there and yeah a part of their ego even
even if it's subconscious yeah that they
don't even want to who were the people
that helped you like that made little
things even just a couple of an AFOL I
can I'll made them all day long because
I didn't blow up
I'm only I've always been like you know
what I ain't here's the thing about my
own specific career is is that you know
I seen Dane Cook's rise and fall
I heard he owes nothing mm-hmm to him
blowing up and then I don't know what is
it doing now I mean he I think it's very
funny yeah I think Dane is a funny guy I
think but I've seen it I you know I was
in a wild world I never had that I was
I've always just been slowly just kind
of working oh yeah and I like that that
kettle
I've been cuddling it right you're that
[ __ ] kettle bruh but the guys that I
help me immensely was and this is gonna
be difficult to say but Carlos Mencia
yeah and Pauly Shore Wow
those are the two people that went in
the 90s
mm-hmm put food in my phone my on my
table man mmm I used to do I did
probably 600 shows with Mencia Wow I owe
and the reason why I'm with my agent man
is because of Mencia he's a nice guy
what is that this is Google Trends
between Dane Cook and Bobby Lee
he's got the Wow look at that oh well
really they do that yeah I'm in the red
yeah so I've got nothing
your highest ever though is right now
yeah Wow look at that Bobby
I know but that's still that that's the
way I said I was the saddest graph if we
put a lesser comic though you'd be oh
yeah put me in Theo in there what about
that kettle puts me a Theo in there this
isn't gonna be good for anybody's you
gonna do this yeah let's do it with you
in the red right now
yeah but he's spiking above me but all
those spikes I'm telling you rogon
appearances all I'm doing Rogen in a wig
I'm okay I can't wait but the blue is me
yeah Wow Wow steady incline and a bump
right now a bump right now Wow
yep right now today literally when
you're on this show looking for you but
you're even above me
what do you how do you google that
Google Trends Google Trends Wow and then
you put just two names in there you can
put up to like six how about this put
Bobby put pandas that's a great one Oh
pandas are gonna kill me Wow Bobby Oh
kind of same
no no pandas are yellow yeah yeah yeah
yeah their way their way Bo yeah we I
know I hear it is that you are growing
recently that's true so are you yeah
yeah whoa is that me is who's in there
me Dayne no media yah be and Panda yeah
yeah okay now I want to say that I want
to put this out there this is a show
that I want to do right yeah I want to
know and I'm gonna ask you right now if
you're okay with doing this and if you
will commit to actually doing this I'm
already gonna say yes to it a premiere
episode right and we're gonna start a
network I think and we're gonna start
our first show is going to be called act
Jack right so here's what we'll do I
will be put into makeup to look just
like Bobby right and then I will do five
minutes of his act on stage
Bobby will have you put in a makeup to
look like me yeah he'll do five minutes
of my act on stage
all that be in the show is all about the
contact and the audience gets to decide
who wins well Q you have to make it a
competition nope we don't have to to
sell it I don't know it's got to be like
but also when I think panel here's the
thing though we don't even have to sell
it we could just let people vote if they
want to online or comment or some right
and we could just put it that's what
yeah let's not make it a comments
at jacked will put it out there will you
do it yeah 100% do it now we can be
interesting
will you say that it's not if I get
permission from you is it okay to
impersonate you and not be racist
because I'm not trying to be really I
don't have an accent only in the certain
parts of my act I'll do it avoid but if
I get makeup or I get a little mustache
or a little you know no but you're
trying to look like me you're not trying
to look like an Asian guy you're looking
at Leo trying to look like about me Lee
won't it look specifically like I wanna
look like you - I'll get the white
makeup
I'll get that bulbous nose yeah dude
I'll go to the mr. Magoo [ __ ] mr.
Magoo yeah do you see me Pizza mr. Magoo
what yeah what an [ __ ] that's what
you look like I can get no text from him
right responses because he rarely is
awake just like pandas how long do
pandas sleep at night could you man up
Nick there's a question about you guys
are sleeping habits okay yeah we got
some fan line question we're gonna get
you out there listen they're not
listening live now there are nothing's
live but how they asking question as we
put a voice means but I want to know
this
I do so would you do it would you do the
show act I just say yeah okay good
Wow hundred sixteen hours yeah panda
sleep ten to sixteen hours all the last
night is I said four five four five
hours last night really yeah but you
could have slept for more I had to do
this that's why yeah I don't want to I
didn't want to sleep through it yeah
yeah and then almost I'm looking at
three new houses like later how exciting
is that being good well you know you you
watch shows like on the home that
whatever the HD yeah HDTV yeah and and
you and you make G TV whatever it is and
you see like oh we're spending you know
a family will spend $600,000 on her
house and it's like a mansion yeah in
like a Waco yeah but here you get a size
this this room yeah for $600,000 and you
know you for you to get a regular
looking house Wow you know infinity yeah
and then it's like oh you gonna have to
put a $500,000 down that's crazy right
that's all I have yeah I mean I have it
Wow but that's all I have so I'm gonna
put that down and I'm gonna go on the
road oh no I have this Joe that's the
only reason why
you can see that my show sucks mmm I'm
getting socks haven't seen it yeah
that's what you said though no I heard
from a lot of people it wasn't good a
lot of people the Sun that was one guy I
mean it was one guy yeah and other
people heard him say it and then some
other people said himself
yeah you saw there's a it yeah you know
it got I don't even laugh when they said
it yeah yeah it got like on this like 36
percent on Rotten Tomatoes which is not
good right but you know all I can do is
look at the numbers and you know and and
yeah and look man here's the thing I
don't think you've really figured out
what the vehicle is it's just the Bobby
Lee show but I want to know right now
would you play a female or an
ambidextrous sexually ambidextrous
friend of mine Oh 100% owned I would do
ie if you had a show Yeah right
and it was the show that I think you're
gonna make yeah I don't I mean as long
as I don't have to do that that many
auditions
yeah I'm 100% into it I don't care what
the money is yeah you know oh we have to
be my friend that might be gare might be
straight might be mam might be woman
yeah 100%
I'd even do it seems naked why I don't
want that I just I can imagine it and it
doesn't make me want to see it more can
actually what I did here can I just show
you what I did yeah okay good but look
look what I did
oh wow I be shaved it huh yeah oh well
Bobby shaved it wow yeah that's very
thank you Swedish thank you and can I
say this yeah I love it
do you really yeah are you shave yours I
mean yeah everybody does dude it's now
[ __ ] that crazy you show your pubes
just recently all of it uh pretty sure I
always get the Clippers always I thought
you I [ __ ] up with a guard and it just
keeps coming off yeah cuz mine look like
Cambodia for a while I could see that
yeah and then it was like it was just
unruly I needn't hated it but now that
it's like bare
it feels so good I like the way my dick
is shaped
I don't everything about it yeah if you
could change one thing about yourself
what would it be and be honest be really
honest you know I wish I was taller do
you yeah I was thinking about doing that
one operation they do in China you know
that operation mm-hmm to make new people
taller oh yeah what do they do
they put more bone in your legs no more
I don't think they do that
yeah they do no they what they do they
they they separate the bones Pol Pot I
think isn't it they separate the bone
the extent the right so they leave a gap
and then the bones grow mmm
to make you taller it's like Bridge to
Terabithia have you seen the movie no I
heard it's a painful though it's okay no
long not the movie - actually the
surgery oh I could imagine [ __ ]
hiding your bones from each other making
a meet up again like it's [ __ ] like
it's the notebook yes the notebook of
operations that way creepy bro yeah
let's go to some fan line questions we
got a few right here and then we're
gonna get you the [ __ ] out of here dude
and this one's perfect it's about
surgeries oh good what I'll do this
question for Bobby I was listening to
him on his podcast with Tom Segura he
said he was going to do a hair
transplant from the back of his neck
oldest patients on the trigons beard
gone there's wondering if it was there
we go through with it still haven't seen
him with a beard yes Bobby
I thank you yeah yeah yeah I'm doing it
cool I've done it I've got back here I
got the part of my mullet taken out and
put into the front
nobody was think I'm gonna do it on my
face no and I think you should as a
beard yeah but I already said on the Tom
Segura thing I'm gonna do it later in
life
well how much later well I'm gonna I
want to make a lot of money first and
like and then I want to get out in the
business who sees that though what are
you gonna do we're gonna pet shop no I'm
gonna have to save money
mm-hmm and just yeah I'm gonna do what
sell wood are you gonna work at a hum
deep but I don't have the world I'm just
gonna just leave no you got to work I'm
gonna leave America while we go to
Hawaii or something like Roseanne did or
whatever and then I'm gonna get the
beard transplant
and no one's gonna see me for like three
years and when I come back I'm gonna I'm
gonna present my new look mm-hmm and I
already have to look because my hair is
receding and I'm not gonna do the
transplant I'm gonna let it recede ooh
but I'm gonna grow the sides out long do
my shoulders and when a full down beard
I'm gonna wear like more monocle no
Morpheus glasses mmm
right open Hawaiian shirts hmm and we
have a really [ __ ] up pan mm-hmm
that's the look good dude you should get
your dick tattooed on your chest I could
see that you don't think let's take
another question another call that came
in you this is Rudy from Chicago when I
got a quest for Bobby Bobby Steele has
stated at the Joe Rogan experience that
if he was ever stranded in an island he
would eat the Asian guy first now what
would you taste like to feel or vice
versa but with do taste like if you had
eaten love you guys guys would you not
wait oh I would love the white really
yeah I have a little bit of [ __ ]
honky in the afternoon no I would do it
out of anger really yeah I feel like you
faked this role that you hate whites
though I don't hate whites cuz a lot of
your friends are white I've seen you
with whites no I love whites Eric
Griffin's half white dude I'm white all
day I hang out once all day yeah but
what I'm saying that in an island
situation mm-hmm I would PT like I would
eat you because I know that I would be
the first on your menu mm-hmm so I'm
gonna get to you first yeah because why
would you want to eat Asians first you
know it
with me I went on a fast one time and I
you know I mean people know this but I
almost [ __ ] they had this do to the
best fathers best boy named Ben and I
think he might have been a man you don't
know you know you guys are kind of
hide-and-go-seek when it comes to what
age you are and but he I was so hungry I
hadn't eaten in five days and I thought
I could eat this man like everybody kind
of I just had this weird thought calm my
head like I could [ __ ] eat this guy
yeah and he was Vietnamese and I knew
right hand the way you say that though
Vietnamese is real crazy like what do
you mean Vietnamese I mean the way you
say it I move on neck like that I play
in the made it's like you're back in Nam
and you're low bruh and you're Kevin
Dillon and you get your shooting of
Vietnamese guys the leg he's hopping up
and down you got year Dan's Vietnamese
do you make it sound like a condiment
day yeah yeah the fries and the
Vietnamese on you squirt a little more
Vietnamese on those dude no I say the
Viet bruh yes yes yeah I'll [ __ ] gum
down a Viet in a heartbeat man yeah I
think yeah Vietnamese people to me very
much a delicacy very much edible and
very like passionate to the bay yeah no
you don't think nah man I think that
what are you gonna eat a deer you need a
black woman who should be pissed
what are you gonna [ __ ] eat yeah her
just you know ya don't have her leg but
she just sit up there like she's dead
but she still that's her life reflexes
you know made of that you know I would
um let's see what we were stranded I'll
be honest it's not a race thing right
it's who I could eat right you know I
mean so it's like a baby a [ __ ] no the
Brad Williams ooh
I could probably eat him I could see my
feet look along I doesn't matter I'm
heavier I do a double leg I'd sweep the
leg right sweep the leg you gonna be
able to do that yeah because all ankle
to his ankles gonna kick I know
I'll sweep his ankle yeah whatever the
bottom has a long ankle yeah whatever
the bottom half of is
like a foot and a half ankle right I
would sweep it okay he'd get on his back
okay I would take a piece of bamboo I
don't know what Island were on Yeah
right
and I would just repeatedly hit his
[ __ ] mmm yeah damn right then I would
stick the bamboo like cuz his head's off
I would stick it through that little
opening where from his net where's neck
is no stick the bamboo all the way in
until just take pic pick him up like
this like he's a popsicle it has a
roasting [ __ ]
and I was just roast him like that and
with his clothes on it as well right
because it was just burn off right his
clothes would burn off unless he's
wearing plastic and what kind of it's
condiment would you put on him oh we
just eat it raw I mean just the elect
well part of the body would yeah at
first that is because midgets have big
asses
mmm that fatty big ass oh all right this
fatty [ __ ] big ass you're going to
hell man oh dude imagine them melting
your mouth that fat
yeah and imagine then you going directly
to him yeah not pass heaven do not
collect 200 you would eat the Asian
don't worry I kind of eat a [ __ ] and
I've said this process that this one's
your Rogen Asians would forgive you
they're so forgiving they're so kind
you have Filipino you know can I just
say this this is when you [ __ ] just
said that it just [ __ ] angered me so
we're because we're like we because we
that's the one thing I hate about Asians
it's because the fact that we just want
to assimilate we don't want to cause any
problems but I'm not that kind of agent
are you
Am I I don't know no dude you've seen my
ad you see how I'm oh you're definitely
a wild Asian what do you mean I mean
you're probably more yappy I'm while
just for being human yeah you're like a
kind of a chubby on athletic Bruce Lee
Khanna you know Bruce Lee of the Spirit
you have like Bruce Lee and your humor
you like the humor you're like Bruce Lee
okay that's a compliment I think yes it
is it is yeah it's a cure like the humor
Bruce what I'm saying though is is that
like Chumlee you're like John's kind of
yeah but what I'm saying though is is
that yeah that's the one stereotype that
we have that we just need to get we need
a bus
out of that yeah you know that's right
you guys got to get [ __ ] aggressive
I'd love to see more Chinese gangs I'd
love to see if Chinese [ __ ] [ __ ]
back yeah I'd love to see a Chinese and
a black person mate and have a huge food
[ __ ] angry Chinese see this - yeah
and this is the one forget about you
yeah
specifically yeah and I don't want to
start any kind of argument whatever but
you know there's a difference between a
[ __ ] in a Korean dude right yeah
what's the difference Koreans it's hard
to guess at their Korean cuz you forget
that it exists Chinese you usually think
about Chinese and Japanese whoa stop
stop stop
you know what I know we've been talking
for a long time yeah if we going on
thing right now
it might take another 30 minutes do it
another time we'll do it another time
what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
absorb what you just said okay I'm gonna
put it into like a little anger thing in
my in my chest store it almost Dora your
princess for the next time but what
you're saying right now is [ __ ] up no
it isn't okay let's just leave it that
let's leave it at that I left it there
the beautiful little princess himself
[ __ ] Cinderella right here we got him
Bobby Lee ladies and gentlemen yeah one
of the song was that one of the sweetest
men in Hollywood
[Music]
oh but when I reach that round I'll
share this piece of my life I can defeat
it in my bones
thought it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself on my
[Music]